talk about another Bowl Las Vegas is set
to host Super Bowl 58 in February 24 and
preparations already underway including
the search for local businesses to help
with the event joining us to talk more
about that are NFL business contact BJ
Weimer along with Maisha Boyce with the
Super Bowl 58 host committee thank you
both for being here DJ if you could talk
about the Legacy and mission of this
program
you know it is so rewarding to be asked
a question like that because the
business connect program for the last
eight years has been to every Super Bowl
making sure that local diverse
businesses in those markets have been
connected to NFL vendors and we know for
a fact that the program works we know
that they're getting contracts but even
better we know that when local diverse
suppliers leave the business connect
program they're stronger businesses
they're more competitive and you know
they're primed to get contracts in their
local market I love it because it's not
just about the time when the Super Bowl
is here it's about moving forward
correct and Maisha there are going to be
some 200 local businesses that will be
engaged because of this and how can
people participate how does that work so
we're looking for vendors that fall
within the categories that the Super
Bowl is going to support so the best way
for vendors to find out if they're
qualified to do that is to visit the the
host committee site so it's LV
Super Bowl hc.com and there they can
find all the information about how to
get involved and there is a specific
search for minority owned and operated
businesses correct yes it's minority
women
um disability veteran and lgbtq plus
owned businesses that is wonderful what
is this going to do for our local
economy to have the Super Bowl in Las
Vegas first time ever in Nevada
I think that there's going to be an
economic and a community impact with
Super Bowl certainly the businesses that
are a part of the business connect
program will have a stronger business
community on the ground locally to
support each other during Super Bowl and
Beyond I love it BJ Maisha thank you so
much I'm already fired up for the Super
Bowl coming to town looking forward to
it Mercedes